hey guys it's Ava dobrik and today I'm
going undercover on the Internet it's
actually me Instagram are you engaged
the picture of me Natalie who's my
friend slash assistant no we're not
engaged we're not dating
we're just friends right Natalie Natalie
has cue cards just friends not engaged
can we get a short tutorial on how to do
the David's mom oh it's so crazy because
I didn't I didn't realize that I do the
same smile in every picture till I
started reading comments and like all my
smiles they're like this here I was just
an interview and someone asked me to
take a picture and I was like okay and I
smiled and no no do we do the David
smile and I was like what are you
talking about this is this is how I
smile I stick my tongue out I think a
little bit when I smile I think it's cuz
I used to be insecure about my teeth
before I had braces so I would literally
stick my tongue out thinking it was
blocking my teeth I don't know and now
it's kind of stuck not this is my smile
posted where's the podcast the podcast
it's um it's probably late I'm really
behind I'm like all social media
postings I'm like a day or two late for
everything it's probably on Spotify or
iTunes you're a millionaire and wear
Levi's yeah what else are you supposed
to wear your person commenting and
you're not using the right from your
what are you supposed to wear when
you're a millionaire Levi I think Levi's
are expensive I don't know I don't they
even wear Levi's I think I wear like
Target brand jeans I'm like I'm really
really the worst when it comes to
clothing I don't spend over 10 20
dollars on clothes because if it's
blackout wear how are you giving out
cars I don't know I don't know how it
got to here but over the last year I've
gotten to give out a little over 15 cars
now which is cool and one of the cars
was a Lamborghini for my friend Heath I
don't know how I get to do that but I'm
so so so lucky and so happy good to get
anybody in my position would give out
cars if they could but
I just got lucky I guess posted
Wikipedia dobrik was born July 23rd 1996
in Kosice Slovakia his family moved to
Vernon Hills Illinois a suburb of
Chicago it's almost close I was we moved
to Ohio and my parents moved first and
then I surprised my mom when my dad took
me up at the airport she thought I was
coming in a completely different time
and I flew over by myself and I cried
the entire trip and then her reaction
was crazy when she opened the door and
by crazy I mean it was pretty tame she I
think she was happy that I was gone for
a little bit dobrik is protected under
daca I am I am protected under daca
that's why I'm still here and I even
picked up on May 15 2000 19 Dover
legally married Lorraine Ashe Jason and
his mother as part of one of his vlogs
that's true my um my buddy Jason told me
I'd never find love so I flew to Boston
to surprise his mother and propose to
her we flew to Vegas got married and
then we flew to Hawaii to honeymoon and
then we flew back and I surprised him
with papers saying I'm his legal
stepfather this is really cool it was
also really cool because Jason's 45 so
he's older than me but I'm his dad boom
read it do many of the vlog squad
members have normal jobs yeah Suzy is a
lyft driver and Vardhan goes to school
fara Don's 12 years old but he actually
makes the most amount of money in his
entire family because he does he does
personalized shout outs where people pay
him to say happy birthday and he's like
the hottest person on the app so he's
making the most he's making a killing I
don't think I left work at normal job
which is kind of sad
favorite video of David in another
youtubers videos I don't really like
watching videos of myself unless unless
I edited them cuz then I get nervous I
don't know what I said I used to make a
lot of videos of Lies and those are all
really really funny those I'll still
watch anyone know what kind of bracelet
David is always wearing the blackened
metal I'm gonna don't have on it was a
bracelet John gave to me
John Stamos I hate saying his full name
because it just sounds like I'm
name-dropping but John gave it to me
it's from his brand and I always had it
and then I got like a rash right here so
I took it off it wasn't the bracelets
fault but I just took it off and then I
lost it
um but I always wear this one I've had
this one on since my freshman year of
high school so I've had it on for like
eight years eight or nine years it
doesn't mean anything I was just in
health class and I asked my friend John
I was like do you want to see how long I
can wear this green bracelet and he goes
sure okay
so I've had it on ever since has no
meaning to whatsoever next Twitter does
anyone know why exactly David Ober can't
leave the country like I know he'll get
deported but why I can't leave because
I'm protected by daca
and basically I can leave I can go right
now but I can't come back
I can't reenter the country for like
another ten years if I if I leave the
country so I'm not like a citizen I
don't have a visa the only thing I can
do where I can leave the country and
come back because if I get married but
Natalie and I are not engaged so it's
not happening any time soon but who
knows fingers crossed
who is david dobrik like what does he do
david dobrik makes videos on the
internet reveals a lot about his
personal life just films a lot a lot of
his day a lot of my last two three years
has been on camera which is cool because
it's kind of like a video diary YouTube
and how does one become David's
assistant asking for a friend
Natalie became my assistant because she
was my friend from my hometown and I
didn't trust anybody else I don't know
how the process works I let Natalie do
all that I'm not good at hiring people I
feel like I just get like connected to
whoever I talk to for the first time so
I'm like okay you're hired even though I
don't like go through the proper means
of figuring out if they're qualified or
not why does Dave his bathroom look like
a public bathroom with stalls my
bathroom has a divide in the middle
where one's a shower and ones the
national toilet but it looks like
there's multiple toilets I've had people
go into my bathroom and I go whoa you
multiple toilets and it just looks like
that
Quora this is David Daugherty his
friends 15 who's videos no I don't my
parents would ask me this question every
time every time when I when I started
making videos my parents would be like
do you pay your friends as like I don't
it's like a mutual thing we like making
videos and they were like well you
should start paying them because they're
not gonna want to be in them anytime
soon and I was like no trust me we all
enjoyed doing them so no I've never paid
a friend to be in a video is david
dobrik dating anyone no David you'll
break is not gay mr. Cryan
how much time would it take to edit a
david dobrik dialog I guess it depends
like how much effort you want to put
into it for me it takes so every video
every video is four minutes to 20
seconds long but each video I have about
five hours of footage so it's kind of
just making like a trailer of the best
part of my day it takes me about like 12
13 14 hours to get it done right now
we've been working on one and it's been
like two days we just we can't get it
right if you don't really care for you
can get it done in an hour
how much of David Derrick's logs are
scripted not that much the only that
scripted is if someone says something
funny off-camera and then we go hey can
you repeat that because it'll be funny
if you say it again people think it's
all scripted it's not how did Josh Peck
and David Ober become friends I don't
know this one this one's this one's
beyond me my friend had his phone number
and he called him and he was like hey
you want to come shoot some videos with
us and surprisingly he was down and then
after we were done shooting with him he
goes hey let's make this like a regular
thing like let me come back and shoot
more videos and I remember him leaving
and I was just like I start like we all
all my roommate just started high-fiving
because it's like the best moment like
Josh Peck is is officially down to being
all the videos this is really cool I was
the biggest fan of chicken Josh the
biggest fan of Jake and Josh those those
these show i watch growing up so it's
it's even it's like I'll call my parents
now when I'm sitting in the living room
and I'll be like look who it is it's
Josh Peck from dick it's crazy it's so
weird because you you forget after a
while that like that's the guy that you
were watching I don't know it's that's
nuts in david darks vlogs when he's in
the car
this is tesla directing by itself for
his he drive in it most of the time i'm
driving it i think they're referring to
like when i film people in the backseat
so I'll have my hand like this and I'll
be looking at the rearview mirror to see
if I'm lining up the shot correctly on
the person I rarely let it drive itself
I had the Tesla there's a new function
on it where it can be parked at like a
grocery store and you can be leaving the
grocery store and you hit it and it
comes and picks you up at the front of
the grocery store I try that the other
day and it hit I got really slowly like
5 miles per hour it hit a guy shopping
cart as he was walking out of the store
so we have to explain to him that it was
a new update on my car and that was a
mess so I don't let it I don't lie to
tribe itself
what's the reason my david dobrik every
vlog is for 20 minutes I would say
because I came from vine and every vine
was six seconds long so I kind of
adopted that and I wanted like something
short that people can watch quickly and
not have to spend ten or twelve minutes
watching what will become a favorite in
the next 10 years this is such a scary
question because I'm always scared of
answering it because I just imagine me
like being completely burnt out in some
ditch and an edit place of me answering
this question and then it cuts to me
like just like completely exhausted and
not like working or not doing anything
anymore I'm just I don't know I'm taking
it day-by-day I don't want to know
what's gonna happen to me in 10 years
but I'm having fun in the meantime
submit take you internet for all the
questions I'm surprised I didn't get my
feelings hurt I didn't cry watch so this
was this was a good run see you guys
next time